each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
hello everyone um I and my colleagues
Kevin and James spent about two two and
a half years working on doing some
reproduction and so that's what I'm
going to show you our replication of
prior studies which is what I'm going to
show you today having this right back
there with the long braids and so our
domain of research is open source
software this is an interdisciplinary
research community I assume everyone in
this room knows what open-source
software is okay good so the typical so
the typical research topics in this area
they really range some are far more
technical in software engineering world
and some are far more social and we're
looking much more the social aspects
like communication patterns coordination
collaboration things like that so the
project we were working on was NSF
funded effort as a kind of proof of
concept for East science approaches to a
little science domain and the goals are
basically to use some existing shared
data sets which for social scientists
are absolutely enormous and for most of
the people in this room are not really
so big we worked to develop our
workflows collaboratively that was
another key point and we wanted to build
a library of reusable components that
was definitely an explicit goal so we
started off by selecting a few papers
for reproduction based on the
availability of data and the suitability
of the analytical approach because quite
a lot of social science research is not
suited toward to this sort of automated
type of analysis so the studies that we
chose to replicate included one that
looked at scale free growth dynamics in
open source projects with developers
some of our own work that looked at
dynamics of communication patterns using
some social network analysis and a
project that are a paper that did some
classification of open source projects
based on their stage of development and
a few of
factors to identify whether or not they
were successes or tragedies the kind of
data that we have to work with for open
source research is really quite diverse
it goes from the purely qualitative data
too far more structured and system like
data which is much more what we're using
is digital trace data this is a
byproduct of the work of the open source
developers it is not intended for
research so while it's relatively easy
to get as far as data goes it's not
necessarily very easy to use for
research purposes the data that we use
comes from repositories the hosting
forges with which you're probably all
familiar like sourceforge codeplex
unfortunately is not part of our
collection at the time but fresh meat
riri porridge etc and the data from
these repositories are pulled out and
placed into repositories of repositories
so that we you know don't get a whole
campus banned from sourceforge by you
know impolitely spidering for example so
I'm just going to speak quickly as a two
of these repositories that we used for
this work the first is the one that we
created with our collaborators at elon
university we have public access to over
300 gigs of data about quite a few
projects from 8 repositories now we very
politely scrape it and then it's parsed
which is uh not fun work and I don't
envy the person who manages that end of
things it's released in flat files and
sequel data marts originally on
sourceforge but now on google code and
we also have a 525 terabyte allotment on
the tear grid at San Diego so this lets
others use direct database access and to
date the requests for access have
primarily been from masters students
doing a thesis but there's there's a
fair mix of the people who are
interested in using this data set the
other main repository that we pulled on
for this work was the source Ford's
research data archive this is managed by
a single pie at Notre Dame who receives
an enormous dump from sourceforge
directly every month it is just
produced and that means it is very very
difficult to use the delivery methods
for us to access it or not particularly
easy but it is definitely an asset so
working with this kind of data are
requirements for analysis tools required
scalability because we wanted to take
our analyses that might go on you know a
dozen projects up to thousands of
projects now this isn't big scale for a
lot of people but for social scientists
this is enormous it is world-changing
scale we needed to do data meshing from
these multiple repositories and we
wanted to do this collaboratively in
part we had to do it collaboratively
because our contributors had a fairly
diverse skill set and that is in some
cases even non overlapping so just for a
snapshot of what that means the first
person i would call data wrangler expert
with data sources good at coding great
technical skills second person be an
analyst competent with are no other
coding skills good at debugging that's
me third collaborators a pie and we all
know it p is due so we chose to use
taverna there were a number of reasons
to go with tabrina i think the most
compelling reasons were flexibility and
the really responsive my grid team and
the supportive community and from
studying open source we know that that's
one of those signals of health to look
for is that there's a lively community
and that the people contributing to the
project are supporting users even when
they ask stupid questions so our work
process was pretty basic for this we
started off by evaluating the data the
methods the analysis the findings and
then we move from that to developing an
abstract work flow together focusing on
functionality now I say abstract work
flow because in the older version of
taverna there were abstract processors
that didn't necessarily do anything they
were just placeholders I don't think
those exist in t2 but you can pretty
much use other components the same way
for planning purposes so once we had
figured out what happen to happen
overall in this workflow then we
basically cut it in half right along the
data to announce
divided we specifically specified names
and forms of the inputs and outputs at
that boundary so that when we went to
bring them together there weren't going
to be any clashes and that was critical
to making this work seamlessly when we
came to integrating them so we
independently developed our pieces we
tested them I had to use dummy inputs
because I was doing the analysis and but
when it came to actually integrating
these partial workflows it took 15
minutes and 10 minutes of that was
figuring out how nested workflows and it
worked so that was just hands-down
amazing success in my book that was so
easy I couldn't believe it and then
finally test the whole thing and give it
a run so one example of the work that we
replicated here excuse me was
identifying success and tragedy of the
floss Commons and this was the
classification project that our study
that looked at 110,000 projects to look
at stage of growth according to a number
of different metrics and we are not only
replicated the analysis but then
extended it in a couple of ways the ways
we did that were parameterizing all of
the thresholds so the criteria for this
classification involved threshold levels
they had at least three releases it's
been at least six months since you know
this or that right so we parameterised
all of those instead of using the hard
thresholds that were in the paper so we
could switch them up when we wanted we
also tested some I did some additional
variations on criterion tests so not
just changing what the constants were
but wholly changing the approach to that
particular criterion and this is what we
came up with this is not pretty but it
is beautifully functional so this
section up here all of this in this big
light aqua box i don't know if that
color comes through for you this is all
data retrieval and data handling all of
it the analysis is all right down here
so basically what happens after the data
got pulled out it went into some of
these criterion tests which fed into a
classifier the classifier used a classic
truth table to go through and verify
whether or not the project fit the
requirements for classification
and an interesting aspect of
implementing it this way is that the
truth table actually revealed to us that
the original author either did not
report or did not consider some of the
potential cases which were due to like
negative cases for example so the key
strategies that made this work for us is
that we really work to make this
transparent and to keep all of the
pieces that we were building modular
because we did a lot of bean shell and
our shell components that would allow
the flexible custom processing we needed
metadata and code comments are critical
and we all know you need code comments
for good software you need them for a
good research as well and then we also
specifically design these pieces for
reuse particularly the data handling
pieces and the tunnel quote shipment
which do all these small transformations
for example they switch between epic
date format to sequel date for mac
format and then back again had to be
done in one of the analyses that I've
run because I could only get the dates
from one data source in one format I had
to change it to epoch in order to do
mathematics on it and then change it
back to sequel so that I could then
query with it so a little bit roundabout
but having those pieces built once they
can be used many times we also assign
the right tasks to the right people the
person who can only code in our should
not be doing data handling for example
and I would note that since then I have
learned some Java so important details
about how we made this work in addition
we're using subversion for version
management management anytime you've got
collaborators working on something like
this you need to do some some version
management and if if we were starting
this today there's no way i would use
subversion my experiment can handle this
much much better at the time that we
were doing this the sharing permissions
and privacy permissions weren't in a
state where we could put unfinished work
and share it among collaborators very
shortly after we basically got the stuff
running they implemented it in what I
would consider the perfect way for the
way I would want to use so I you know
hats off to my experiment team that was
just lovely
um we set up server caching because we
were testing and testing and testing and
testing and every single time we had to
go fetch the data and fetch the data and
that took forever so that little piece
of work made a big difference for
actually doing the work and then there
was a big piece of work that made a big
difference and that was creating an owl
ontology to Matt between the two
repository data sources this is really
non-trivial and had it been solely for
this project I don't know that it could
have gotten done however it was also
part of James's dissertation work so
there was further imperative for that to
happen and in order to extend the
analyses we not only implemented some of
the author suggestions for future work
which is very interesting because it
immediately showed us in about 10
minutes that what they hypothesized
doing as an alternate totally changed
the results of the classification
everything that was 11 form became
indefinite so we also implemented our
own variations I'm using some different
methods of examining those criteria and
I found it really remarkably easy to add
and modify these pieces once we've built
the rest of the structure it was just
swap this piece up for that one or add
another one here so that was that was
really great we were able to run
announced he's on much larger data sets
than the original author Saudis did and
that's partly passage of time so a paper
that was produced in 2004 didn't have
the data through 2007 um in terms of
reuse this was a major goal for us and I
think probably the most successful for
our own work we specifically designed
for reuse anything that was for sampling
your data handling had no constant only
parameters I broke that rule once and
paid for it because I found after
presenting the paper at a work at a
conference that we've forgotten to
change one of these date based
parameters from you know 14 days to X
days so I was much upset with myself for
having missed it that one time but it
shows you how important that had become
as a part of the way we were doing this
um we spent a lot of effort on the data
handling but it really paid off because
all of those components that we that we
built and all of the sub workflows that
look real messy in that prior workflow
we just drop them into another one now
and that that really makes a huge
difference in terms of the time to
results for any subsequent data analysis
we want to do from these data sources
and it moves the challenge from dealing
with data to research which is where I
think it ought to be there are a few
challenges with work using the workflows
initially software usability was real
bug bear some of the bugs just really
wreaked havoc with what we were trying
to do i have to give great credit to the
migrant team the usability is constantly
improving t2 is miles ahead of t1 and
you know I've been really thrilled with
the direction of that and in fact they
brought me to Manchester for a couple of
weeks over the summer so I could tell
them exactly what was going wrong with
some of the usability so they're really
open to that feedback and that was
wonderful data handling no matter how
challenging me expected it to be it was
always harder so that's that's a caveat
with the data handling this is a case
we're building once to retrieve data
from a data source is fabulously useful
so you sink in you know 40 hours for one
repository but then you know you save
yourself 40 hours every other time that
you go and do the same kind of data
source so we also had no existing web
services or appropriate examples to
emulate for us web services weren't a
very feasible option we didn't have the
infrastructure resources to support them
very limited potential user market so
it's kind of you know negotiable whether
or not that would actually be worth the
time and effort for us and when it came
to looking for examples pretty much all
the examples are bio science oriented or
so general that it didn't really you
know help me figure out what I needed to
do there were no real social science
examples but there are now some of the
barriers to uptake that we encountered
when bringing this to the open source
software research community are what i
would call little science issues and
that's paradigm attic clash various
researchers have different
epistemologies different methods
different theories that they wanted to
test the lack of agreement overall is
what really holds up this kind of
adoption of this kind of a tool there's
also a lack of incentives to collaborate
there's no funding imperative it's not a
huge community with
set standards on how we do our work so
some of the structures that apply in say
biology or chemistry in terms of you
know this is the way the lab is
organized this is the way the rewards
are set not so much in open source I
also would consider there to be a
bimodal distribution of the requisite
skills to make this work many social
scientists cannot code and anything to
do with our to do with Java scares the
pants off of them and then on the other
end of the scale many of the people who
are doing research into open source
software are software engineers and they
don't see any point in using the same
tools as anyone else and will happily
tell me that I should use Python as well
which becomes very insulting by the
third fourth by six twentieth time
you've heard it but overall I found that
students are far more willing to
experiment with these tools and
approaches sitting down with a couple of
students at dr. Alkin Sorcha over the
summer I think I you know got some
believers out of that and and so you
know they're looking at using it for
their own dissertation work which is
great and just to show you that it was
not all for naught we've continued using
the tool for our own work and
repurposing some of those elements that
we've built so this is just a quick
example of some research recent research
that we did which is a estimation of the
user base and potential user interest
the size of these populations based on
common release and download patterns
that we observed in community style open
source projects downloads in particular
are a proxy for user interest and common
or for project success because people
assume if they downloaded it and people
are interested that's successful but for
a number of reasons downloads are very
very poor metric and so we want to look
for something just even a little bit
better so what we have here is you know
our theoretical model of what we think
is happening with the downloads so
there's some base rate of
experimentation but when a release
happens the active users update and so
all of this area under the curve is the
size of your active user base and we
don't have very good ways to verify this
but this was the working hypothesis
so and this is and this is why we
thought this would work really well so
quote normal download relief pattern for
bib desk which is reference management
software so that every single time you
have one of these kind of pink red
verticals which is a release of the
software you have a spike in downloads
at the same time and there's a little
sawtooth pattern hair day of the week
this is absolutely typical for any kind
of web bait web-based user behavior and
also notable in this particular version
I don't know how well you can see it
from the back of the room is that I
think there's only one spike that's a
notable spike on this whole thing that
is not associated with a release that's
right here so we suspect it was you know
project of the month or something like
that so while i was at manchester just
for comparison once i had fixed this
particular workflow and gotten that
constant out of there i ran it on
taverna tuberose download really
patterns show external effects so yes
you get the spike with a release but you
also get spikes for no apparent reason i
sat down with some of the folks and dug
through some records isn't it what's
going on with these dates and we could
easily identify that you know at this
point there was really candidate that
went out and there were two
presentations and you know that's
probably why this is offset just a
little bit with the presentations were
quite on the same time you know 1.5
right there with a huge spike in
downloads so that's the kind of thing
you expect to see what you don't expect
to see though is you know all of these
random ones that we just couldn't
explain and we dug around quite a bit no
way to figure it out so what we take
away from this is taverna is not normal
and in the community developed
open-source sense and that all of the
the work that the team does in terms of
speaking tours publications tutorials
other events those are influencing
adoption directly so that didn't get
necessarily at what we were looking for
initially but what it else what it does
also tell us is that we can use this
particular workflow and running on
projects and identify the ones that are
typical community development patterns
and the ones where something else is
going on
like taverna so we also have poster on
east science approaches for open source
software researchers if you care stop by
and have a look at any point papers
presentations even a tutorial video on
how we did this with taverna are
available from our website and the my
experiment group there is for open
source software researchers so if you'd
like a look at some of the stuff we
developed and the other people who are
interested that's where to go and find
it so any questions inside well the main
constraint that we face is that we're
using the data that we can get from
repositories this is not insider data we
don't have anything to corroborate
except what we can get so from a
business perspective you know one would
use web logs and things like that to
validate some of these things but in the
open source world we've got what you
know what's in the repository so people
look at things like you know time
between releases how recently the last
release was made how regular releases
are how long it's been going how many
contributors how many downloads and not
just cumulative downloads but you know
rate of downloads over time whether it's
increasing or decreasing my general
sense is that it's really hard to tell
much especially when you're throwing a
lot of spaghetti at the wall basically
because there are so many different
indicators that they're testing and
trying out that it's really hard to
identify whether any one of them was
really contributing overall in terms of
evaluation
if you're more vickers say our project
this that's expected but if you're not
part members also say our project what
we do as saying your project
but the point being things using this
approach is that we can put together the
analysis project
yes
was there any correlation between the
number of people working on projects and
then other success factors such as
downloads or multiple releases I have to
say I can't recall because it's been a
quite a while since i looked at the raw
data from that particular bit of work i
would say in general actually sometimes
they're often with sampling on these
projects there's thresholds as a minimum
of say seven developers because once you
get 27 developers it's non-trivial
coordination why seven I don't know
which is part of the reason we did it
this way so we could so maybe three is
where it gets to be non-trivial
coordination so I can't directly answer
that one however I can probably dig out
a nice big flat file of data or if you
really want
well thank you